yeah so apparently this weekend movie
has come out that is the true story
about what is supposedly the most daring
Coast Guard rescue in u.s. Coast Guard
history but I'm going to review this
movie first to be fair because I saw
this movie first but let's just embrace
it folks let's just bask in my absurd
lack of priorities because that's me
Jeremy Jones movie reviewer and Men of
[ __ ] priorities
50 shades of black so 50 shades of black
should be a gold mine it should be easy
as [ __ ] to make this fun enjoyable and
funny because it's making fun of 50
shades of gray we'll see what happens I
was kind of interested in this movie
because a haunted house too is a bad
movie but there were a couple scenes in
there I was laughing really hard it was
dumb stupid but it happened this movie I
don't think I laughed I chuckled once
and it's in like one of the last scenes
in the movie I'll spoil it for you right
here [ __ ] I'm not gonna make you sit
through an hour and a half of this [ __ ]
to get to it he's gonna whip the girl
there are a bunch of whips from iconic
scenes in movies where a black dude got
whipped you have like glory 12 years of
slave Django Unchained all these
different whips and it goes over and
says Joe Jackson is just a belt there I
laughed I was like that's pretty funny
the rest of it holy [ __ ] was a movie
made that is actually worse than 50
shades of grey I mean well granted four
completely different races this movie
has no wit there's no charm there's no
there's no humor behind the jokes like
this movie was written by someone who
does not understand humor it's like
Spock was like I'm gonna write jokes for
fifty shades of black I think this is
funny at least that would have the left
bright and logical kind of humor this
just it didn't have humor every joke of
this movie so simple when you see this
setup you know exactly where it's gonna
go and you're like but they're not gonna
do this because that's the easiest God
they did the easiest possible version of
a joke for that scenario every time bar
none everytime boomers are some Marlon
Wayans on Jimmy Fallon seems like a cool
dude I'd want to hang out with he's not
a guy I would want to write a movie for
me though no it's like when they're
trying to be clever in this movie it's
just awkward and that awkward moment
could be edited out but they didn't edit
it out I mean they just wanted to phone
it in then make a dick or ball joke and
that's that there's nothing clever about
dick and ball jokes people make that in
elementary school and then people kind
of grow past it because of like hey my
brain is expanded I'm smarter and more
intelligent the tendrils of humor can
reach farther than they did when I was
in sixth grade but not here
not ever and like I noticed in a lot of
other Marlon Wayans spoof comedies it's
not like its own thing it's not like
airplane it's not like naked gun it is a
recreation of scene for scene for scene
of the movie it's spoofing which makes
you kind of Borges you're like I've seen
it and I know now exactly where this
movie's gonna go which would be fine if
the jokes were funny but the jokes were
funny guys in the end it was one of
these things where I was like they're
making fun of Fifty Shades of Grey I
feel like I should watch the movie let's
just see where it goes
mm-hmm instant regret movie wasn't funny
the people in it weren't funny the humor
was awkward or it was just toilet humor
dick and ball humor really simple as
[ __ ] that its target audience can't even
buy a ticket to because they're not old
enough to watch the movie yeah Fifty
Shades of black is Doug [ __ ] [ __ ] do
they keep making these things why does
it happen alright so 50 shades of black
have you seen it what did you think
about it if you have I am really sorry
and if you have it what's your favorite
spoof comedy whatever it is comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more